remember attack together
every time i give you a 3-4
breathe on four and attack on one
i put so much love and effort sweat and
blood and tears into this band program
[Music]
we are the best marching band in the
country
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is abraham duffy jr and i am the
head drum major for the sonic boom of
the south
[Music]
we bring
something that no other band brings
excitement
jaw dropping in your face entertainment
the jackson state drum rangers are the
heart of the band
we are known for our showmanship
but what a lot of people don't know is
we teach music to the band we lead the
band we help with formations and we also
help guide the band
[Music]
and the beginning of august we practice
for about 20 hours a day
from 5 a.m to 12 a.m in the morning
you really just have to find time to
sleep
five times
exercise
not only is it physical training it's
also mental and emotional training as
well
it's needed in order to be a part of a
program of our caliber
what goes on is a lot of playing a lot
of playing and a lot of playing
and also marching marching marching
march and marching
[Music]
[Applause]
being a physical trait gives you
endurance it helps you play better and
perform better and also gives you muscle
memory
[Music]
this is my fourth and final year as
young major
my hope for the future of the band is to
just excel
be better than the bands before them be
better musicians
just to finally be at the end it's
bittersweet but i
am going to lead and never look back
because i know i made my mark
[Music]
[Applause]
you